[Music]  probably nobody expected this  on the first sad photo of the friendly  spider from the neighborhood  spider-man wears two masks at once  namely a mouth nose covering  and his usual suit the message follows  directly below the picture apart from  that  not much seems to have changed since far  from home as at first glance the suit is  identical to the one from the  predecessor  not much is known about the content yet  but many fans are looking forward to the  appearance of jamie foxx's bad guy  electro  and benedict cumberbatch as a new mentor  doctor strange  dr strange's knowledge of multiverses  could certainly be beneficial to spidey  as the marvel and sony's universe  collide through the appearance of  electro the release date of spider-man 3  is expected to be december 17  [Music]  2021  [Music]  you